hi everybody my name is Pete frazzela
I'm a developer advocate on the Google
Analytics team I'm joined here today
with Andrew Wales he's a developer
programs engineer on the team this is
just another quick update we want to do
a recap of what's taken place the last
month or so give you guys a little bit
of heads up on some new features that
came out possibly do some changes that
may have taken place that you should be
aware of so with that we'll just get
started and get right into it in it and
you're going to take it away with a
little bit about analytics Jess and some
collection changes yep and actually we
got a couple changes to a cookie domain
configuration and cross domain stuff so
we'll check it out right now so the
first thing I wanted to highlight was
that we now have this thing called
automatic cookie domain configuration so
before with analytics j/s or even ghas
you had to specify what domain you
wanted the cookie to be reading on now
we let you supply this auto argument for
analytics j/s and what that means is
when you do that analytics Jas is going
to write the cookie at the highest level
domain possible so for example you were
trying to write a cookie or if your site
was example code UK analytics chest
would try to write to coat UK that would
obviously fail in the next domain we
would try would be example co uk that
would succeed so that's where we'd write
the cookie too so this is kind of the
new default way to set up your cookie
domain and it should work in all the
main use cases like one site with
multiple subdomains or if you're working
with multiple domains setter so it
simplifies that whole process sure so
this is but actually polyus recently
announced that change logs and
officially added today right yeah we
actually had it out for a bit but we
just added at the docks and we updated
all our code snippets on website so this
is now like the default way to implement
perfect vehicle cool so the next update
is for cross domain auto linking for
forums so for those of you who are
already using it we already offer an
auto linking plugin for analytics j/s
that will automatically append the
parameters that you need to any links
that are pointing to another domain so
that you can track across those domains
successfully but what we just added with
this update it was the ability to make
this work for forms so both get and post
forms you add this true argument at the
end here
that will will try to upend those
parameters to the end of the form action
as well so one thing about this one
though you definitely make sure you test
this on your site before you actually
deploy it so maybe some cases where this
if you have something custom going on
with JavaScript on that page it might
not work in all cases but it should work
in mode so just make sure you test it
out before you to play it and again just
another way to make things simpler for
cross domain tracking and then the last
one last update this was actually out
for a little bit as well but we just got
it documented this is enhanced link
attribution for analytics jas so this
was a feature that existed for gijs what
it does is it lets you let's here in
page it makes your in-page analytics
reports more accurate because it allows
you to disambiguate between links on the
same page that are pointing to the same
URL so really quickly the way this one
works once you load the link ID plug-in
which you'll see they're basically if
you have a link on the page that's
pointing to a URL in this case like page
2 when a user clicks on that link we're
actually going to write the link ID to a
cookie and if that link for example if
that anchor element didn't have an ID we
would look up in the Dom to try to find
a parent element that did have an ID and
would use the first one that we could
find and then on the next page when you
actually send the page view will include
whatever that element ID is in the hit
as part of this link ID parameter and
that's the way we're able to in the
in-page analytics report tell that users
came to this page to not from some other
link but from this specific next button
for example so because of all that
because we rely on element IDs to make
this work it's really going to be most
accurate when all of your links have
unique IDs or at least their parent
elements should at least have unique IDs
so it looks it'll look up the actual Dom
to check if there's IDs above rendering
the parrot elements exactly and that's
actually configurable so you'll see I
think we're showing you an example of
the code snippet but you'll see that
there's a couple configuration options
you can configure like the name of the
cookie how long that cookies going to
last but you can also tell us how many
levels up in the Dom you want us to look
for that element ID cool that's a nice
little addition yep okay moving on to
the AP is we just like last week or so i
think it was we renounced three
different changes for the multi-channel
funnels I call reporting and managed may
pass there's a few things some of its
new data and a couple different features
so the first thing is multi-channel
funnels we added some additional data
around AdWords conversion pass in
interactions so it's this is more about
the IDS so we already had pathian
interactions for Adwords things like ad
group and campaign but this allows you
to query for IDs now that are associated
with those specific dimensions so it's
pretty straightforward you can go and
look at the reference talk for the
multi-channel funnel and see the this
new data is in there and get some
descriptions for these particular
dimensions the next thing is the co
reporting API we've added some new data
again to the corporate API the minute
was actually something that a lot of
people are requested to have minute
level data and now we actually have this
so you can query by minute which is
pretty a pretty impressive actually when
you do it for a long period of time it's
so crazy to get that much data back then
we have the enth minute which is kind of
an indexed value for which will show you
basically index values from the over the
time here that you've specified and then
if you have the audience reports enabled
within Google Analytics you we also
added some dimensions and metrics around
the audience report reporting data so
this is now available through that so if
you have the access to that data you can
now pull this out through the core porn
API and again take a look at the query
dimensions and metrics explore the link
is there at the bottom and this is where
you can go and look at all these new the
new data and see exactly descriptions
and things like that and whether they're
alive in segments as a minute is that
also new in the front end as well yes
this was also so you might have seen it
also in the front end to the web
interface you would have seen it shown
up there and then it was released
through the API a few days later so go
yep available at those places
we also enabled segmentation for a few
different so there's source medium this
is a new relatives we added source
medium which is combination or
concatenation of source and medium so
this is also now allowed in segments and
then we have local item revenue which is
also an out allowing segments so not all
dimensions and metrics can be used in
segments and you can go to the
dimensions and metrics Explorer again
there's actually an option to select on
the front page there's a little checkbox
there and you can you can select that
and I'll show you which dimensions and
metrics are allowed in segments and then
also if you view the description of any
dimension or metric it'll indicate
whether it's a lab in segments so these
two have now been changed to yes allowed
in segments and local item revenue is
revenue in the local currency the
currency yes exactly yeah okay cool the
next thing is the data table response
format that we've added to the core porn
API so this is if you let use the
corporate API and you make and you made
any requests you'll know that the data
comes back and there's kind of two main
components that data is the column
headers and then there's a rose object
and the rose contains all of the data
ordered by dimensions and followed by
metrics so in this example we have some
data for the query that says it's google
nexus 7 is the mobile device info i
think is the dimension in this case and
then the metric of 180 so this is kind
of the default standard response you
would always see with the cobra point
api however we know what that lock
people want to take this data and use it
in some sort of visualization and one
visualization tool you pray that we have
here obviously is the charts API so part
of the charts API one of the format's
that's used quite extensively is this
data table format so we've added some
capabilities now to the core reporting
API that allows you to get data back
return in this data table format so this
is what the default response would look
like and this is what the response would
look like with this new parameter so if
you make a query to the core reporting
API now you can specify this output
query parameter and if you set it to
data table you'll get something that
looks a little bit like this so instead
of the Rose object sitting within the
response you're going to have a new data
table object and that's going to contain
two separate lists there's going to be a
columns list which indicates the IDS
labels things that this is the data
table format for basically column
headers
you'll get that and then you'll also get
the rose but this is within the data
table you get this rose which contains
your data so it's a similar set of data
but it's in this data table format the
cool thing about this is that you can
take this data table extract that out of
the object and actually feed it right
into google charts the visualizations
and it'll just work with that particular
like there's pie charts just columns
there's all these different different
visualizations are available and this
response format works directly with them
so yeah just makes a little bit easier
to get people to go from like requiring
the data to actually getting it in
insurance I know it's awesome so it's
really nice and easy so another
important change that you should be
aware of your using these dimensions and
metric here is that we've deprecated
three columns here so one is the is
mobile so this is that this was a
dimension that indicated yes or no
whether the visit was on a mobile device
and we had the similar thing for his
tablet and then we had the entrance
bounce rate and these have been
deprecated so I encourage you to go read
the dedication policy and this explains
kind of the process that we take to
deprecate dimensions and metrics and
also what you should do and what steps
you should take next when we actually
deprecated data there's a bad removal
instructions kind of section do that in
a policy there so yeah whats happened
here actually is that we have a device
category dimension and so we've
deprecated is mobile and we've we've
recommend that you use instead a device
category equals mobile so you can set
that as as part of a segment or or
filter right so this is also the same
thing for the is tablet we're getting to
suggesting you should be using device
category equals tablet to get the zactly
the same data so those are the two main
things there for the kind of mobile
tablet space but then the engines
battery we should be using instead the
visit bounce rate right so these are
kind of equivalent measurements we're
just cleaning things up a little bit
making it more consistent for this
particular at miss Baker case
so with this change was also affected
something in the management API so we
have default segments in the management
API you're probably familiar with this
there's always a list of default
segments we provide like and one of them
was mobile traffic and then there was
one like tablet traffic but that mobile
actually included tablet so it was kind
of like confusing maybe a little bit for
some people in terms of what they were
getting so we've cleaned this up and
we've changed these around just a little
bit so you'll know in the if you use the
management API you'll know that the
default statements have an ID associated
with them so they're actually negative
numbers and prior to this change the
negative 11-11 was was just mobile
traffic and it's been renamed to mobile
and tablet traffic so includes both of
those now so we include mobile tablet
that actually hasn't changed from a data
perspective you wouldn't see any change
there actually but we've also changed we
just made sure the name is consistent we
have tablet traffic for the negative 13
ID and its tablet only now and the
definition of that segment is device
category equals tablet the definition of
the negative 11 is device category
equals mobile or tablet or mobile and
tablets are and finally we added a news
segment this is a new default segment it
did not exist prior to this change and
it's negative 14-14 and we have a title
of mobile traffic and this definition of
this is the mice category equals mobile
so if you've been using these segments
make sure if you check your queries that
you have you have any saved queries you
might want to just review them to make
sure you're getting the correct data
that you think you're getting based on
these new segmentation default segments
that we have and you can go and review
this at the management API reference
there's a explains me how to list these
out and get this data back oh so this
also obviously affects core important a
management cuz management is API is
where you get the segments and decor
port and API is where you actually use
the segmented missus man
okay that's pretty much it for this for
this month or so we're getting towards
the end the holidays are coming so um
will provide links for all of these
changes that we've discussed and here's
some additional resources I want to
check out again for all the dimensions
and metrics tough really you should go
check out the metrics dimensions of
metric Explorer it has all comprehensive
data and gets updated automatically with
these changes yeah with that thank you
very much for joining us today if you
guys want to keep up to date with
everything that's going on we suggest
you follow us on the blog we have
Google+ and Twitter handles you can
follow us at and please subscribe to our
changelogs a lot of these things get
announced through there this is
definitely that's the kind of the main
source for all this stuff but thank you
guys for joining us I think that's
probably our last show for this year
right it is yeah always come everybody
have a good holiday have a good years
and we'll see you in 2014